before the flood has been my three-year  journey exploring the subject of climate  change while making the film we traveled  around the world to learn more about the  effects of climate change on the planet  and all of us and I had the opportunity  to speak to scientists world leaders and  activists on the urgency of this issue  before the flood will air globally in  171 countries and 45 languages  commercial-free on the National  Geographic Channel on October 30th and  to make sure as many people as possible  see this film National Geographic is  making it available for free to all of  you just about everywhere you can watch  it on YouTube Hulu iTunes Facebook  Twitter Amazon and Google Play climate  change is an issue that affects all of  us so please tune in and spread the word  thank you very much  before the flood a world premiere event  on National Geographic watch it  everywhere  beginning October 30th  [Music]